we've talked before about how there are
sort of benign conspiracy theories and
then there are conspiracy theories and
disinformation that when people believe
them
have very very real uh real world
consequences and with coronavirus the
disinformation and the conspiracies
have very real repercussions if you
don't accept the science
and you don't wear a mask and you don't
social distance
you keep having indoor gatherings people
get the virus and some of them
die the repercussions are very real now
you might have heard
that utah's coronavirus numbers are
exploding
so badly that their republican governor
put in place
more guidelines and a mass mandate
mandate
and explained that many hospitals are
nearly full
or completely full utah's case numbers
have been spiking dramatically
they're now up to about 3 000 cases a
day that's
a ton for a state with only 3 million
people in it deaths are also up although
not as dramatically for now
as the cases although that could change
as the hospitals are increasingly full
we know that
the death rate tends to go up when that
happens well there are people in utah
one of the most right-wing states in the
country that think it's all a lie
what i mean is they don't even believe
that the full hospital is really full
and certainly not with coronavirus
patients conspiracy theorists started
driving
to utah valley hospital in provo utah
claiming
that the parking lot is so empty the
hospital can't possibly be full
of covet patients so what did they do
they didn't just
stay in the parking lot they invaded the
hospital they
entered with video cameras to document
what they believed would be a completely
empty
intensive care unit now fortunately
these people did not actually get access
to the icu
that would have been just you know even
more insane
but had they been able to get to the icu
they would have found
a full icu with coronavirus patients
nurses and doctors and staff
under huge strain from dealing with a
full icu
and the pandemic now the reason that
there weren't many cars in the parking
lot
is because there are number one huge
restrictions on visitors at hospitals
right now because of the pandemic
also many of the people in the hospital
with kovid
didn't drive themselves to the hospital
because they were too sick
so they don't have cars there guests
aren't allowed so guests don't have cars
there
that's why the parking lot seems
relatively
uh not full things are so
bad in utah that they are recruiting
medical professionals
from out of state to come in and help
and expediting credentialing out of
state
medical professionals to be able to work
in utah
imagine for a second if these people put
as much time
and energy into coming together
to deal with the pandemic rather than
invading hospitals imagine how much
better off we would be
imagine if these people when we learned
about the virus and understood that
cases were rising and how it's spread
imagine if all of these so-called
truthers and skeptics and deniers
actually did something to help the
situation rather than hurt it like
distributing masks as an example or
figuring out
you know a grocery delivery service
maybe for elderly folks who aren't as
comfortable
with ordering amazon fresh or delivery
services or whatever
to get groceries delivered so those
folks could stay home and reducing the
number
of elderly and at risk people who get
the like you know i could go on for an
hour just saying
almost anything that they even just
staying home themselves right
almost anything they could have done
other than
doing this skeptic stuff and trying to
invade an icu
to get video of an icu they expect doing
nothing
would be better than what they are doing
and imagine if these same people
these types of people put as much time
into dealing with any societal problem
like
if we had the conspiracy world
dealing with climate change if we had
the conspiracy world deciding hey you
know what we're going to eradicate
hunger like anything if the conspiracy
right
was helping us rather than working
against
us there are so many problems that we
could have
solved at this point in time and it is
really tragic and
you know the in the same way that i
talked about earlier how do you
deprogram 75
nearly 75 million trumpists and we talk
about
trumpism as a cult and we've interviewed
stephen hassan about
how trumpism is like a cult in many ways
in that same way
um how do you deprogram the covid people
now one of the things we have talked
about is
when cultists and conspiracy theorists
start to see that their beliefs have
consequences at scale
sometimes that will deprogram them with
kovid there's a very clear path there
right it's
i'm a denier a relative gets sick
and or dies from kovid you were
deprogrammed by seeing
that your skepticism at scale has
confidence
has consequences and that people die and
we saw examples of that
if you think back to the democratic
national convention we there was a woman
whose name i forget now but who
spoke very passionately about her father
who
was a trump supporter uh almost to the
very end uh
didn't believe that the virus was
serious got coveted and died
and that this changed his worldview it
changed her worldview and
and that of some others it can happen
but you still
saw at trump rallies even days before
the presidential election of a few weeks
ago
people with shirts that said you know my
my cousin died of covid and i still
support trump i mean like
you know boisterously and extravagantly
and
aggressively um uh flow flaunting
their ignorance really really sad stuff
but uh this stuff has real consequences
and we are seeing
it very much so when you see me sitting
here at the microphone oftentimes i'm
wearing a shirt by a company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i
asked teddy stratford to be a sponsor of
the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it
also has a special type of collar that
prevents it from drooping down
and spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things really do a lot to
make a big difference when you're
looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout